welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and holy exploding
meat suits the boys season 3 just
dropped a new trailer today i'm going
frame by frame to break down all of the
bloody details the trailer features a
brand new song by imagine dragons called
bones the lyrics repeat the words i'm
losing all control cause there's magic
in my bones honestly i thought we'd been
watching these soups lose control but
this plus all the bodily explosions in
the trailer promises that this season
will blow the bloody doors off the magic
in my bones line is particularly
interesting as it plays towards one of
the biggest reveals we see in the very
opening shot of the trailer we see billy
butcher staring himself down in a dirty
bathroom mirror and his eyes begin to
light up this confirms that this season
will explore a similar plot in the
source material where the boys get a
hold of compound v and take it to level
the playing field between them and the
diabolical soups sweat beads up on his
face spot has tested compound v on
children with mixed results but not yet
on adults butcher will likely face some
side effects there's another mere shot
of homelander in his penthouse in the
room is a portrait of george washington
along with several paintings of the
revolutionary war similarly the boys
appears to be gearing up for an american
vs british smackdown between homelander
and butcher only now the roles are
reversed with homelander representing
the power of privilege and butcher
representing the common man as imagine
dragon's warble waiting till the reaper
takes my life an image of black noir
flashes on the screen implying that he's
a harbinger of death starlight clenches
her fist during a photo-op in another
parallel shot we see mother's milk
gripping the back of a chair tightly
eyes locked in a gaze at two
prescription bottles sitting in front of
him perhaps these pill bottles do
contain compound v and that's why he's
looking at him like he wants to chuck
them in a garbage can although compound
v seems more like a drug that you'd
inject than a drug that you can get
prescription pills for so maybe mother's
milk is finally getting treatment for
his ocd or these pills counteract the
symptoms and side effects of taking
compound v frenchie is that vat's newest
attraction rave maeve's inclusive
kingdom the capitalization of maeve's
sexuality was first introduced to us in
the tie-in web series seven on seven
with cameron coleman a closet is filled
with articles and files tracking vote
soups one reads queen's woman killed in
high-speed pursuit obviously calling
back to a-train atomizing huey's
girlfriend robin there's also clippings
featuring several supes we've yet to
encounter all pointing to payback what's
payback you ask well aside from being
the title of the very first episode
payback is a secondary group of supes
also created by vot who are basically a
parody of the avengers in the same way
that the seven is loosely based on the
justice league looks like we're finally
seeing the payback group this season one
article mentions a woman being paralyzed
in a hostage rescue by tech knight a
batman slash blue beetle iron man-esque
sex pervert from the comics there's also
federal bureau of superhuman affairs
wanted posters for europa who's a spoof
on nightcrawler in the comics the other
big missable details in these articles
point to jensen ackle's character
soldier boy a captain america parody
character we'll get a closer look at
later in the comics soldier boy is a
legacy title held by three separate
characters with the modern soldier boy
being a meek insecure dude desperate for
a spot on the seven this will be changed
for the series however as jensen's
soldier boy will be the sole character
sporting the moniker and is teased to be
worse than homelander according to these
newspapers soldier boy is considered
missing or killed in action perhaps
explaining why we've yet to see the
prominent character appear in the series
then there's a parody of the kendall
jenner pepsi ad where she solved racism
by giving a cop a soda here with a train
doing the same thing with a turbo pup a
pro homeland or musical sequence is led
by super sonic a re-imagination of
drummer boy from the comics super sonic
used to be an old flame of starlight
when he was drummer boy apparently he
has a public drug problem but he
rebranded a supersonic after rehab while
ashley bennett is banging the nerdy
screenwriter of donna the seven in a
bathroom stall he accidentally pulls out
a chunk of her hair if you recall from
last season trichotillomania and stress
causes her hair to fall out yui and
starlight smooch at the premiere of the
dawn of the seven film you can see dawn
on the poster behind them homelander
pokes a train in the stomach and grabs
him by the neck to threaten him he used
a similar tactic on starlight in season
one congresswoman newman stands in an
alleyway and makes a man explode into
tiny little people pieces and holy
homelander y'all that is one mighty fine
all-american dildo i'm gonna bet that
handmade models will be available on
etsy no later than this weekend it's
being proudly shown to cameron coleman
host of seven on seven and basically the
tucker carlson of the boys universe back
at brave maeve's inclusion kingdom we're
introduced to the crimson countess she's
another member of payback a parody of
scarlet witch and has her pyrokinetic
abilities as well as similar looking red
energy balls that she uses to absolutely
obliterate whatever poor bastard was in
that homeland or mascot costume damn he
was probably only making like 16 bucks
an hour they did him dirty whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you're more than just your credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in just five
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com newrockstars or click the
link in the description below that's
upstart.com new rockstars don't forget
to use our url to let them know we sent
you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com new
rockstars kimiko snaps huey's arm and my
guess is that she's either doing this to
force him to take compound v with the
rest of the group or to test and see if
the compound v he's already taken has
worked next we see some old-timey
footage of soldier boy in his prime
followed by the deep watching some
people get it on and the reflection of
his pupil he appears to be at some kind
of an orgy i'm sure that the cephalopod
watching him get guts a few moments
later is super jealous newman blows the
jaw off some poor sucker in an alleyway
in the next shot and then we see black
noir eating the most disgusting bowl of
cereal i've ever seen at what looks like
a chucky cheese-esque dining
establishment probably a buster beaver's
pizza restaurant that was teased in
seven on seven we later see black noir
sketching its mascot maeve practices
some six sword moves soldier boy gets
his ass kicked by another soldier in
khaki and starlight witnesses the most
horrific thing i've ever seen a human
exploding out of another human's body
the sign says lucky but this dude is
anything but i mean marvel fans have
been asking to see ant-man climb up a
guy's butt since thanos but it looks
like payback's termite will be the first
to go where no shrinkable man has gone
before butcher clutches a vial of
compound fee in his hand and then we see
his eyes glow yellow once more in the
next shot but like two seconds later
he's vomiting up bright green sludge all
up in huey's mouth gross i'm guessing
that this is one of the less pleasant
side effects of being shot up with super
drugs homelander is apparently a huge
hit with this world's right winger
characters he's hosting the equivalent
of a maga rally and in the crowd you can
see a man dressed like the viking guy
from the january 6 capital insurrection
after homelander descends towards a
crowd of people in sharp contrast to
when he went bonkers with his eye lasers
and slaughtered a bunch of people last
season ryan's eyes glow red like
homelanders as he rips off some sort of
necklace perhaps one that his dad gave
him and ashley rips out even more of her
hair a blonde woman perhaps a young
malory is seen running through a
battlefield that looks like it could
have taken place at the same time as
soldier boy was originally active this
might be a flashback scene explaining
how the two know each other in the next
scene a train is battling blue hawk and
appears to be calling him off attacking
a room full of people of color it would
make sense to have another secretly
racist superhero take the place of
stormfront this season if she's still
recovering from her injuries apparently
homelander has replaced his weird
milking fetish from regular old lady
boobs to milking a cow ish men will
literally milk a cow instead of going to
therapy next there's a fun snippet of a
song and dance scene performed by kimiko
and frenchie i don't know about you but
this kind of reminded me of that musical
episode of scrubs that took place inside
the mind of a dying woman i think that
this may be a fantasy sequence that one
or both of them is imagining we see
soldier boy in action again once again
shown in an old time even yet as he uses
his shield to swat away bad guys just
like captain america as he fights he
seems to show little regard for the
carnage which could be why that little
boy is screaming and covered in blood in
the next shot in the last shot of the
trailer we see soldier boy ripping off
all of his medical equipment as he comes
out of stasis whoa we finally see a shot
of butcher's powers he launches
payback's gunpowder straight into the
side of a van take that you guns rights
activist butcher only needs
these guns to fight
shortly after he shoots yellow laser
beams out of his eyes i personally
cannot wait to see billy butcher in
action this season and this trailer
definitely has me hyped for more boys
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitneypuppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you